the Democratic Party no and they just
ignored it because they're pretty much
as racist as he had like he said
Democrats have racist as party you think
they said well he's a Democrat so be
cool well alright my name is Jamil mail
I'm calling action with open minds we
pull you Center for black business
owners and influencers and actually if I
could grab two minutes of your time that
would help - I just have about four very
important questions regarding the
current business political climate in
Virginia and it could be anybody who
works with the n-double-a-cp in any
capacity all right all right you want to
talk to you the political action chair
okay but okay what's what's their name
maybe I have an email and a phone number
oh man that'd be great what was your
name sir I'm a woman oh I'm sorry ma'am
what was your what was your name ma'am
my name is I'm just writing this down
don't worry not in trouble enough and I
just I appreciate just really let know
that you called me that I call you sorry
and it's a man of color himself oh yeah
oh great okay cool cool are you ma'am
yep awesome great okay can you give me
that phone number uh the phone number is
[Music]
it could I ask you three questions
because it would still be relevant we
are asking people who are not only black
business owners but influencers that's
why we're calling the n-double-a-cp to
anyone of color honestly on their
opinions it'll take two minutes of your
time I just got like three four
questions there yes or no answers and
will really help me out okay okay so
just a couple of quick things as a lady
of color with the governor's support of
gun control policies like universal
background checks make you more or less
likely to support him would he have no
however no effect whatsoever okay that's
not an option but I will write nothing
dad let's go next question okay what
Governor North was proposed 1.2 billion
tax increase make you more or less
likely to support him I don't really
remember okay he what dealing with the
tax increase so wants to increase taxes
about 1.2 billion in the state so we're
just as about the general policy
increasing taxes would that make you
more or less likely to support him on
what he plans to do with the tax revenue
yeah I don't mind the tax increase but I
want to know what it or that's fair
that's been I don't have that
information in front of me like I said
these are just general questions to get
a temperature I appreciate it only two
more questions does governor northerns
position on abortion that it should be
freely accessible up until and including
the third trimester does that make you
more or less likely more more likely to
support him okay more follow-up would
his support for post birth abortion
after the baby has been safely delivered
make you more or less likely to support
him that's not really what Rob's daddy
just that it badly again I'm gonna say
more more likely to support post birth
abortion right would right would
recently surface photos of him dressed
in blackface and or was a member of the
KKK in his medical school yearbook make
you more or less likely to support him I
just came from speaking at a protest
where I told him to resign
so you been a a the NAACP's official
position that he should resign it
doesn't really have that much to do with
the photograph it has to do with his
current policies that are not oh well
that's very interesting could you tell
me this isn't a question but I'm
personally very curious so it's not the
black face or KKK but his policies
specifically what policies have prompted
you to ask for his resignation the Union
Hill compressor station would be one
okay Union Hill is an historically black
community they and they are building an
incredibly Dominion energy wants to
build an incredibly large compressor
station their continued but yeah all
right well they want to build one of the
biggest compressor stations in the world
in Union Hill and they claim that it is
not a majority black community at all
well I don't know it's like a majority
black you know being from there myself I
know it's like I float like a plurality
though right which should be no out well
well again they're saying that it isn't
an environmental justice issue so they
can go ahead and do whatever it is that
they want I'm talking about though we're
just Center sorry that's outside my
purview
we're just talking about racial issues
yeah word all right yeah yeah correct
he'll issue I'm sorry because my uncle
works worked there he's probably gonna
work as a job as a contractor on the
compressor so how is it how is it a race
issue forgive me and I appreciate you
taking the time
me but I'm not I'm not tracking you know
well again we're talking about placement
of the compressor station and they also
want to put one in Ellington Virginia
which is also majority minority
community so all of these poisonous
toxic assets end up in poor communities
and or communities of color so they love
Indian reservations Indian lands black
owned lands or anything where there's a
majority of or people who they get your
can't fight back and I think that
Governor North them is doing this on
purpose like to target people look this
is all news to me like I've never seen
it as a racial issue so I appreciate it
you know you're right right right
here's another issue slightly different
topic hotel any threshold it's five
hundred dollars in Virginia yes we push
the governor to push for an amount of at
least a thousand dollars preferably
fifteen hundred the original spreche
hold of two hundred dollars was created
thirty seven years ago we explained the
governor that if we want equivalent
money and this is in 2017 to the two
hundred dollars it would need to be at
least seven hundred dollars he was not
willing to push for more than five
hundred so as you know in Virginia if
you are convicted of felony you not only
have a felony convictions you lose your
right to vote from a lifetime that's
right and you can't you can't carry a
firearm either so I got a I got ever had
yes it's a whole new set of rules yeah
right right right so again if you look
to your governor for leadership
I suggest you visit this website Poor
People's Campaign - VA Docs
Oh RT poor and Arabic camp it's art so
are the ones that ones and camp poor
people
campaign yeah right - VA dot party
website that's a tough one to find a lot
of articles there on Union Hill okay can
I ask you just a couple questions here
so when has it become officially like
the n-double-a-cp position to ask
governor Northam to resign when did that
happen Saturday Saturday afternoon
Saturday oh cool it google it so yes the
NAACP googly but it has nothing to do
with the black face and or KKK pictures
in his medical school yearbook to look
at their statement so and can do their
official statement that they made okay
so yes DNA is been very involved with
Union you okay so it's about Union Hill
it just so happens well well coincide
and the other right and the other
problem of course is the governor
basically apologized on Friday
and then on Saturday said oh gee gosh
golly that's not me right right right
but but but but again the bigger problem
is the fact that originally on Friday
when he was apologizing he didn't know
if he was a pea picturing black days or
be the picture in the Koran oh no what
you think what you think which one you
think it was you think it was blackface
or you think it was a KKK I think it was
black faith in that picture you think it
was black face what do you think would
be worse though like if it was if he
were in blackface or if he went to KKK
cuz that's my final question I was gonna
about to ask y'all but I know you
educated me on Union Hill I don't even
know happened in my own backyard no no
no I Ament about it no mo but do you
think that it was black you think it was
blackface but would it be more
if it were blackface or if it were KKK
which do you think is worse because I go
back and forth your spy the KKK is worse
okay um blackface is an insult the KKK
killed and dismembered black people yeah
that's true but the black face is ugly
you know you get a get a ten a Kiwi shoe
polish and rub that all over like it
seems it seems like more in your face
like an insult like look I'm looking all
black in my face and it just you know
like they could put on some makeup get
some Maybelline and make it something
that's like actually looks like a person
of color that's like a pardon my
friendship um this is me off the record
okay but that's like a big Q when they
do with that you know what I mean well
right now now but again remember the
other comment that he made he talked
about being in blackface to quote
imitate Michael Jackson in a dance
contest right okay but then to continue
adding ridiculousness to an already
bizarre situation I decided to only use
a little because as a lot of you know
I'm sure it's really hard to get that
black shoe polish off oh my you know
Ralph no no don't no no most of us don't
know especially people with color people
of color we don't know we're never put
no shoe by the way I love you've a try I
can't put no white shoe polish on and do
white face it can't happen it's just
it's just quick as a matter of fact our
protest one of the people mention that
when she was a little girl she wanted to
be Marilyn Monroe for Halloween it said
it never occurred to me to paint like a
white man that's also a problem like
whatever happened to Rosa Parks you want
to be you want it you want to go out
there you want to be some some to slept
with JFK behind the back on the back of
this first lady like Kim Marilyn Monroe
oh yeah Rosa Parks we got strong women
we got Maya Angelou
strong people who they can look up to
that's the problem that's what we trying
to work here that's why we work with
black in splinters and black business
owners because it's like if it were my
daughter I'd say hey Marilyn Monroe I
don't want to use this word I don't want
to teach this word a Marilyn Monroe
ain't nothing but a ho aim higher can we
aim I know I know
okay fine I appreciate you taking the
time and I am going to call this mister
let me ask you this final question what
would North American your support if
anything
well he's not about to regain my support
again I look at he sold out for money he
talks a reasonable game but when you
look at policies where it really helps
he's not there nobody home but what
could he do
is there anything he could do to like to
make it up to the black juice' do you
think for the black community it's just
your people okay here's my opinion he
can resign and then he can go and he can
work on helping to do on the 400 year
anniversary of black people showing up
in the United States okay that's alone
you can try to learn something this year
people yeah now and again here's the
thing about Governor North yes governor
north and grew up with what folks he
went to a desegregated school so at some
point he decided that he would rather be
a good old white boy than a person who
was a good person of conscience and
recognized contributions and humanity of
the people he grew up with that's a good
that's a good point it's like decided
racism it's not it which is even worse
because like some people are raised
you're like man you don't you don't know
he's just raising a farm you know like
he ain't ever seen
but a man who has and then it's like you
know what I'm a hey black people no
matter what deaths that's the worst kind
of racism that's like almost what and
and again remember I'm talking about
oh and I won this dance contest because
I get imitates Michael Jackson normally
when you look like before you look at
white people in here all they can't
dance well because he probably went high
school he went to a predominantly black
high school rock dance you learn to
dance well learn to dance with black
teenagers and dance they naturally at
I'm sorry wanna dance
he grew up with that yeah and then to
consciously make a decision
oh I'm gonna throw that part of my life
under the bus now that's like throwing a
born a baby under the bus
ain't no right now now now now I am
going to assume that you went to college
why do that because I'm relatively
articulate yeah okay well thank you very
much
yes you walking Rick all right all right
now people have nicknames when ralph was
in college they call the coup man why
where would it go I called him Kumail I
kun right kun they called him come man
Oh might I call him and this was p.m. I
see most racist sexist institution in
Virginia why did they probably call him
who man because my guess is to basically
entertain the white boys he dressed up
in blackface and imitated the black folk
he dropped it that's that's terrible
that's terrible let me ask you a Ralph's
claims he doesn't know why he has that
nickname how do you have a nickname and
you don't know why you have a nickname
yeah well it happened it's happened
before like I have I have a guy who
calls me he calls me cinnamon toast
crunch at place I go when I get ribs
now hey I say well why do you call me
Cinnamon Toast Crunch you said cuz I I
don't know and I was like that's fine
you could come I do like it though so
like it's cool but it didn't make a
whole lot of sense I think you just like
cinnamon toast crunch see like me we
were cool I think that's what it is let
me ask you this stuff this is all new to
me right they call him cool man
that's new to me that he was raised did
the MJ like yeah I believe you I believe
it's new to me but let me ask you this I
know the n-double-a-cp
supported North them right the election
I have that correct yeah yeah and when
you're looking like at brick having all
what happened like did he did he not do
this right and everyone's coming out
there and they know it like why do you
think
ain't nobody surfaced this before not
like these pictures it's not like it's
junior high yearbook
right and older things get interesting
meaning did the Democratic Party know
and they just ignored it because they're
pretty much as racist as he is and it
was kind of an you know hey boys will be
boys and it's part of the you know
good-old-boy Club and you know Ralph the
good old boy stuff so it never occurred
to them to you know think that it was
bad or say gee you can't run under the
Democratic banner
I just find it believed that ain't
nobody know this before he wrote like
awful research in it held a primary
right let alone going out to a general
this time this Ariella didn't find it
Gillespie didn't find it you know should
basically be killed but what about
journal like though like what about CNN
you know ABC why didn't they find it I
mean they can find stuff from you know
when they would tell them up Cavanaugh
gore sick like the car clubs they were
in people you know 7-elevens they hung
out with they can't find a guy who's in
blackface and or KKK that remains to be
seen like ain't nobody famished
you know me apparently not nope nope
nope and either a they weren't look
or be they just gave him an automatic
because it'll be white boy white boy
it'll be white boys yeah and because
like he said Democrats have racist ass
party you think they said well he's a
Democrat so he cool we gonna let him
through even though he's cool man
MJ black face shoe polish would like he
cool because it's Democrats well right
and then again his medical school is
going you know oh my god we can't
believe that and so now the new article
said there's a whole bunch of other
races pictures in the that same yearbook
and then they get the page numbers and
they tell you what the pictures up oh
you know it gets interesting what people
gave a path to and thought was perfectly
okay that is interesting because listen
is to 2018 I don't believe for a second
that people who can find all this
information didn't have access to it I
think you're right I think they just
turn right they just look the other
words all right well listen I appreciate
you taking the time I'm gonna give a
call to this this man have his phone
number here thank you so much and thank
you for in life enlightening me on some
of these issues I appreciate I'm gonna
look it up all right thank you okay
bye-bye thank you take you hey there
Here I am drinking from my mug in a
button-down how often do you see this
never so do me a favor and yourself
click one of these videos playing in one
of these boxes here or a subscribe hit
the notification bell also because
subscriptions don't really mean a whole
lot if you really want to support the
show join my club if you don't then
there's no helping you